Who has more shoes, men or women? I asked this question to everyone at Udacity.
If you'd like, you can take the poll yourself and give us more data to work
with. We're going to do a t-test to see if men or women have more shoes. Our
null hypothesis is that there's no difference. The mean number of shoes owned
by females, is equal to the mean number of shoes owned by males. Or that the
difference is 0. Which gender do you think has more shoes? That will determine
our alternative hypothesis. One alternative hypothesis could be that females
own less shoes than males. Or that if we subtract the number of shoes owned by
males by the number of shoes owned by females. We get a negative number. Or
maybe we think that females own more pairs of shoes than males, in which case
the difference will be positive, if we go in this direction for the
subtraction. And if we don't have a guess, then our alternative hypothesis will
be that they're different. The difference is not significantly equal to 0.
Let's go with this alternative. I know a lot of guys who have a lot of shoes.
And I also know a lot of girls that have a lot of shoes.